what are the states 32 happy right well
you know we talked about the contest in
access the reason that you know states
to do happy writers was started by
somebody named Joey tuccio and Joey
basically that the whole entire company
was connecting writers with executives
to listen to pitches and these again are
managers agents directors development
producers people who are actually
looking for material at the time like if
they're a manager they have to be
willing to take on new clients so on and
so forth what I was blown away by with
it was as a writer who was unwrapped at
the time and who was entering contests
to get access okay you know you enter a
lot of these contests and you kind of
fly blind you get no feedback okay with
when I watch for Joey was doing with the
happy writers and saw how here were
writers being able to no matter where
they were in the world be able to pitch
directly to any one of these executives
via Skype I found that to be completely
fascinating because now the no
unsolicited material rule goes away
these people are looking for material
you're getting immediate feedback ok on
your pitch and to me that was
fascinating so that's why we went out
and acquired the company the main thing
to me all the time when it comes to
writers is access how do you get to
somebody that's going to make a
difference and that was what was so
beautiful about this company and we've
had over 300 success stories you know
people either being signed sold option
money options not free or placed on
shows I mean it's been a remarkable
thing it's so rewarding for me as a
writer because again like I said earlier
there are so many snake oil salesmen and
there are so many ways that you could
waste your money and as a screenwriter
more than any other discipline in my
opinion like it bothers me you know as
an actor when i see you know bad acting
coaches of people trying to make you pay
for you know head casting and you know
for additions all that criminal activity
that i think is just you know horrendous
but it's so much worse for screenwriters
right now because there are so many
people praying online you know saying
I'm an expert i'm an expert i'm an
expert i live in you know huntsville
alabama and it's like you know I'm i but
you know I'm a consultant it's like wait
really like you know come on so that was
why it was so important
to bring that company into the fold
because everything is about access and
you're getting immediate feedback its
immediate gratification you know for you
and who doesn't want that and so to me
again I just coming full circle to me
it's all about access and that's you
know the most important thing if you're
a writer
you